cool з резиденція піцу купу шкоди від
фірми краще зніму зайчику рубці обласного
ні пити потреби сучасного футуриста по
бачати отрута заважав президент витікати
yanukovych
чим несіть проїжджати на менше 20 тисяч
людей
освітлення русі та гурію краплі гельцер
поставив же сир активіст майдану по
тролінг догляду що його дні значок
собі вид готові і чи потрібно догляду то
житло екс-президента
теці ви влада ви каналу постанова про
націоналізацію ми ж я
яку верховна рада у хвали на сир
цьому нора взимку і так і 129 вікторі
тиснява зайві землі з 1000 форумний
на pid контроль ну януковичу фірмам сюди
досить за 2 роки ніхто не прийшов у не
інтер зація метро яніно баланс на я
поставлю ну на екскурсії прокурора
всі генпрокуратура через суд так і паркан
сумно влада на кому розпоряджайся ми ж
віримо проте конфіскат темою et que
потрібні вали шакали суд визнано
довели за щось приємності владні до
donna законного права на низами та
корупційних схем до школи будив night
star задайте ефективний інтерпол треба
ситуацію на міжнародній рушниці
консультації душу ду для процедури
спеціального так званого заочного
заслужено x ці процедури буду
роздрукувати та судом буде прийнято
рішення дуги по досліджуваному залежить
конфіскують сезони у темно адже в рази
позитивного рішення суду активісти на зло
шато каламутимо вже гиря а для процедури
передачі його майна
законом та україни не прописано чітко
це ми то у нас е передати звідси ж
владність вони просто передати удар
живність омоте
гарантію шеннон і розкривати що не мережу
вона вранці а nemo живи не про книгу
тридцять п'ять тисяч євро за зростання кожен
турист та активісти нфл нинішній java
вези нас і мотиви витрати і пропан вуличку
promise ми ж вірив статус національного
природного парку